according to at least the canadian food
guide at the moment baby's first food
should be meat so they've finally
switched that because it used to be iron
fortified cereal and then they're like
wait a minute we have one of those but
it's a whole food meat so i switched her
over to meat she doesn't need any grains
she doesn't need dairy she doesn't need
soy she had sugar one time when it was
in a sausage my mom gave her and she
screamed all day like one of those kids
walking through the airport that are
screaming and you're like what's wrong
with her parents but other than that
she's perfect so right now she eats i'd
say like 80 percent meat fruit and then
she'll have carrots and parsnips i
figured that if she got to about five
she'd probably be able to figure it out
herself like if you give a two-year-old
a cookie and they're like sugar high or
something and screaming they're not
gonna be able to know but if you're a
five-year-old i figure if you eat
something it hurts your stomach you can
be like that give me a stomachache so
i'm just trying to get her to an age
where she can kind of eat intuitively
like she's a little tiny angel and i
attribute a lot of that to diet